having invested a hundred and fifty
thousand pounds and with a quarter of a
million pound load from the national
brewery Israel and partner Tara are at
the wit's end
pissed through your hands classic
example in business trying to run before
you can walk
how quiet is it the restaurants losing
money the the bar will be supporting the
restaurant themselves have job but more
than 50% in comparison to two years ago
and that's provided to get it back there
is very desperate
how many crossroads do I still give it
another go well do I return the case to
the landlord next month and say I better
go and do something else we don't know
the kind of guy that giving easy Israel
is up to his neck in debt and doesn't
even have the security of owning the
building
if this goes tits up he and Tara will
lose everything in a last-ditch attempt
to win back customers
Israel has employed one time one of the
fighter pilot
now high-flying executive chef Phillip
blaze - avocado and shrimp with 25 years
experience
Monsieur blaze came hot from the
multi-million pound stables of Belle go
and Planet Hollywood I thought well why
not give a try you know to the
countryside of England Planet Hollywood
I had a hundred and fifty people working
for me you know so here
it's a lot different you know I've got
two three chefs you know we get some
great feedback but the only problem is
that the guests don't come in even on a
dead cert like Valentine's night out of
84 available seats only 24 have been
booked but at least that means the
missus and I can get a table
from the Valentine's special menu I
bought it a scallop and shrimp cocktail
for mains and a tiramisu creme brulee
for dessert sorry I decided to bring it
myself because I have trouble getting a
waiter thank you you're welcome
microwave rice straight away just uh
just a mess for me I really got nice
colors they just need cooking sort of 10
seconds each side though the chewy with
overcooked dried prawns Phil's nemesis
and Maitre D' is 25 year old and six boy
Dave Boehne I think you need to have
quality rather than quantity on a night
like tonight treat people with the
respect they want and the special MNR
how was your meal sing we'll go straight
to the you can do nothing
did you ask the it's a memory cycle
isn't it Tim super burly so did you work
it said robbery Alok kicks and I'm not
dealing you on complaining I ordered
salmon and which sounded lovely and but
it just wasn't quite cooked at least my
pudding should be a safe bet
it's a French classic so Philip should
be able to make it with his eyes closed
and it looks like he has company it's
liquid it's the first time we actually
I've never had a runny creme brulee
should ask for straw [ __ ]
how come on it's not alright yes me
thank no no no no you don't look any do
it okay someone you're [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
go back to your restaurant anglo-french
relations seem to have hit a new low
we made hard work of nothing and what I
didn't experience was any passion well I
did think that the scallop dish which I
was actually very very good the ones I
wore like rubber and I'm really sorry
but I've never known a Frenchman and to
make such a [ __ ] and brûléeing all my
life we've got a lot of work to do awful
food bad service cool [ __ ] you no
definitely not the place for me
[Music]